صور زلزال تركيا وسوريا القاسيه تهز
العالم والمشاهير يحشدون الدعم للضحايا
بريتني ريهانا ريال مدريد والهلال اليكم
الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
بينما لا تزال اخبار عمليات انقاذ ضحايا
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا
مطلع الاسبوع الماضي تتصدر عناوين الصحافه
العالميه كرس العديد من المشاهير حول
العالم حساباتهم على المنصات التواصل لحشد
الدعم للضحايا في البلدين وقدم مشاهير عرب
التبرعات لدعم جهود الانقاذ والمتضررين
ففي سوريا كشفت نقابه الفنانين عن مبالغ
نقديه تبرع بها فنانون سوريون لصالح
المتضررين في المحافظات المنكوبه الى جانب
حمله نظمتها النقابه للتبرع بالدم بينما
قام فنانون سوريون اخرون بالتبرع عبر جهات
اخرى مفضلين عدم الكشف عن المبالغ التي تم
التبرع بها خاصه بعدما اثار الكشف على
الارقام التبرع نوعا من الجدل على منصات
التواصل الاستمرار في قيام حفلات في هذه
الظروف كان مثال جدلا ايضا فبعض نجوم
الغناء العرب قرروا الغاء الحفلات بينما
قرر اخرون التبرع باجورها بشكل كامل او
جزئي لصالح الضحايا ومنهم من قرر التراجع
عن احياء ح في اخر لحظه ماني مستوعب انه
انا هلا بدي البس بعد شوي واروح على حفلتي
بعتذر من كل الناس يلي كان المفروض تحضرني
اليوم انا ما رح كون وراح اتبرع بقد
المبلغ اللي انا متقاضى من هيدي الحفله
لكل الناس المتضرره الناس فعلا المتضرره
وقام العديد من الفنانين السوريين والعرب
بالمساعده في عمليه جمع التبرعات بشكل
مباشر او موكبه ايصالها سواء من خلال
مبادرات اهليه او عبر المنظمات والجمعيات
المتخصصه انا الان في معبر
الزيتون
هذه
هي الاغاثه السعوديه
لاخواننا السوريين
عالميا ردت بريتني سبيرز على ما تم تداوله
مؤخرا حول معاناتها من مشاكل تتعلق بصحتها
النفسيه وخطط لتدخل المقربين منها
لاقناعها بالعلاج في تدوينه عبر حسابها
الرسمي على انستجرام قالت فيها بما معناه
ان اختلاق القصص عنها يشعرها بالغثيان
وربما تضطر للتوقف عن النشر على انستجرام
رغم انها تستمتع بذلك لكن من الواضح ان
هناك الكثير من الاشخاص لا يتمنون لها
التوفيق بحسب تعبيرها لكن نجمه البوب
الامريكيه المثيره للجدل لم تتوقف عن
النشر بل نشرت عده مقاطع فيديو ارادت ان
تظهر من خلالها انها بخير وتستمتع بوقتها
وكشفت انها تتناول احد الادويه المضاده
للاكتئاب لا اكثر
اما ريهانا فكانت محطه انظار ملايين
المشاهدين في امريكا خلال تقديمها عرض
استراحه ما بين شوطي نهائي سوبر بول الذي
نظمته رابطه كره القدم الامريكيه يوم
الاحد عرض رهانه الذي امتد ل 13 دقيقه
اعتبر تك مبهرا لمسيرتها الفنيه على مدى
17 عاما وكشفت صور العرض عن خبر اسعد
محبيها وهو حملها بطفلها الثاني بعد قرابه
التسعه اشهر على ولاده طفلها الاول
واخيرا وعلى سيره الكره احتفع عشاق نادي
هلال السعودي بتحقيقه المركز الثاني بكاس
العالم لانديه كره القدم بعد مباراه وصفت
بالمجنونه فاز فيها نادي ريال مدريد بخمسه
اهداف مقابل ثلاثه وتوج بلقب مونديال
الانديه للمره الخامسه في تاريخه